j'ouvre notre second débat consacré à la
révolution en Iran plus de quatre mois
après la mort de Massa Amini cette jeune
Kurde iranienne arrêtée par la police
des mœurs parce que son voile était
soi-disant malmille et manifestations
continuent des condamnations à mort
aussi Marion vigoureux
ce vendredi
encore de l'Iran des milliers d'Iraniens
des fils pour crier leur opposition au
régime un soulèvement populaire qui se
répète chaque vendredi 4 mois après la
mort de la jeune Macha Amini la colère
des Iraniens ne retombe pas elle
s'amplifie même
car en face le régime répond par la
terreur arrestation en masse et retour
des tribunaux révolutionnaires qui
depuis le mois de décembre condamne ta
mort et exécute les manifestants le 14
janvier dernier à lire et Jack Barry un
anglo iranien et pendu pour espionnage
au profit du Royaume-Uni réponse de
Londres
son exécution est l'acte lâche et
honteux d'un gouvernement kinésitent pas
à utiliser la mort comme outil politique
pour faire taire la dissidence et régler
des comptes internes
[Musique]
le Royaume-Uni qui réf de nouvelles
sanctions tout comme l'Union européenne
ou là aussi les choses bougent le 16
janvier à Strasbourg 12000 personnes
venues de toute l'Europe manifestent
pour demander à l'Union européenne
d'inscrire les Gardiens de la révolution
sur la liste noire des organisations
terroristes
oui
nous avons définitivement atterri dans
un Moyen-Âge islamique et nous attendons
des gouvernements européens qu'ils
apportent un soutien en particulier à la
jeune génération la jeunesse iranienne
ne veut pas de ce régime
si les euros députés y étaient
favorables les ministres des Affaires
étrangères de lueurs réunis aujourd'hui
à Bruxelles ont finalement refusé de
fichiers comme terroristes le régime des
mots là voici ce que déclarait
d'ailleurs ce lundi Joseph Borel le chef
de la diplomatie européenne c'est
quelque chose qui ne peut être décidé
sans un tribunal une décision de justice
est nécessaire en revanche de nouvelles
sanctions sont prises elles visent une
trentaine de personnes et organismes
impliquée dans la répression des
manifestations
le régime iranien les Gardiens de la
Révolution terrorisent leur peuple jour
après jour il est donc important que
nous introduisions ici aujourd'hui un
quatrième paquet de sanctions contre le
régime iranien et en particulier contre
les Gardiens de la révolution
de son côté le régime iranien durcit le
ton et prévient qu'il répondra de
manière réciproque à toute action
diront affront toute confrontation le
recours à la pression et aux outils
politiques est inacceptable et la
République islamique ne change jamais
ses positions face à la pression à noter
que cette montée en tension intervient
alors que la situation économique de
l'Iran ne cesse de se dégrader les
sanctions américaines et européennes
aggravent la situation et désormais
l'inflation dépasse les 46%
jusqu'où ira la violence du régime des
Mollins en ont débat tout de suite avec
mes invités sherine hardakanim bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes avocate et membre du
collectif Iran justice farivalid bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi directeur de
l'observatoire de l'Afrique du Nord et
du Moyen-Orient à la Fondation Jean
Jaurès Bernard Hourcade bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes géographe directeur
de recherche et mérite au CNRS auteur de
cette Iran le paradoxe d'une nation
publiée aux éditions du CNRS justement
c'était en décembre 2021 Mathieu
croissanto utorise politique est resté à
mes côtés évidemment je voudrais
peut-être qu'on dise où en est le
mouvement parce qu'on peut avoir eu le
sentiment avec voilà la trêve de Noël en
France peut-être une information qui
s'est décentrée que que le mouvement
c'était calmé sherine hardakani est-ce
qu'il y a moins de manifestations oui ou
non alors écoutez moi l'information que
je peux vous donner c'est celle qui nous
vient de la part de nos relais dans la
société civile puisque moi je suis
avocate donc mon commentaire sera
évidemment sous cet angle là ce qu'on
assiste en fait à une évolution des
modalités de la mobilisation c'est à
dire que les mobilisations qu'on a pu
voir à au lendemain de la mort de Massa
Amini ont changé c'est plus tellement
des grandes mobilisations avec de la
foule et encore que vendredi dernier on
a vu aza Eden notamment qui avait des
grandes manifestations avec plusieurs
milliers de personnes ça va plutôt être
des modalités désormais par exemple
lors des funérailles notamment des
personnes décédées les gens vont se
rendre spontanément vont converger vers
les lieux des funérailles et il va y
avoir des véritables meetings politiques
qui vont se faire sur place avec des
slogans extrêmement durs à l'égard du
régime donc on a ces différents modes de
mobilisation par exemple des petits
tracts qui vont être distribués dans la
rue quand on a vu par exemple qu'il a
neigé attéhéran c'était des petits
slogans qui étaient
enfin inscrit dans la neige c'est plus
ce genre de
mobilisation là plus spontanée alors on
voit pendant que vous ne parlez les
images on les remontrer de donc
effectivement la manifestation de de
vendredi farival c'est une c'est une
manifestation qui ressemble à celle qui
ont pu avoir lieu depuis 4 mois c'est
une forme un peu différente et puis
surtout parce que on revient aussi à
ce que la répression provoque dans le
dans le mouvement les les violences les
condamnations à mort les exécutions oui
il faut pas oublier que la répression
elle est elle est très sanglante vous
avez des exécutions des peines de mort
des jeunes qui sont assassinés c'est des
meurtres d'Etat donc quand même face à
une répression absolument atroce même si
c'était le cas dès le début et en
connaissance de cause les Iraniens
manifester dès le début ils connaissent
aussi la nature du régime la
manifestation de Zoé Nantes c'est
presque tous les vendredis ils sont
assez réguliers dans leur manifestation
c'est une région qui
nous avons des régions très différentes
en Iran mais c'est aussi ça qui est
intéressant dans le mouvement femme vie
liberté c'est une unité un peu dans
cette diversité iranienne la région du
Bacchus ils sont plutôt croyants et
pratiquants sans vouloir généraliser
donc ils vont ils se rendent en grand
nombre à la prière de vendredi et à
chaque fois après la prière il manifeste
et bon ils ont un côté très en ce moment
anti-régime et ça date pas ça date pas
d'hier après sur les modèles étaient des
manifestations et des moments je suis
tout à fait d'accord c'est de toute
façon c'est un long processus ça n'a pas
commencé avec le mort de Marsa mini
c'est tout un mouvement culturel et le
politique très profond de la société
civile on peut avoir le sentiment en
France que ça s'est calmé mais c'est pas
vrai parce que les militantes les
militants les activistes c'est comment
et continue le combat on a vraiment au
début quand même de quelque chose je
pense de longue durée après
effectivement il faut attendre des dates
clés par exemple quand il y a quelqu'un
qui est qui est tué ou assassinant on
sait que 40 jours après ça sera
l'occasion d'une manifestation là on est
à quelques semaines de l'anniversaire de
la révolution 79 donc j'imagine qu'il y
aura
sans doute des mobilisations vers le 22
le 11 février si je me trompe pas donc
et voilà elle a l'opposition aussi
essaye de s'adapter face à un régime qui
fait tout pour imprimer les syndicats
les partis politiques et les oppositions
naïve mais quand on parle des
oppositions en Iran
qui parle-t-on politiquement
politiquement question difficile à
répondre moi mais de manière simple et
synthétique de tous ceux qui sont contre
la République islamique donc mais moi je
dise aux efforts et qui mais oui après
on peut rentrer
dans des nuances mais aujourd'hui ce qui
est clair c'est qu'une grande partie de
la société de la jeunesse et pas que de
la jeunesse saint-jeançon on dit la
jeunesse mais aussi de nos parents et
nos grands-parents qui sont contre la
République islamique donc demain
beaucoup d'études le montrent même si
c'est très difficile parce qu'il y a pas
de sondage à proprement parler politique
de représentation il y a pas de
représentation politique de l'opposition
de parti politique vous avez des
militantes et des militants qui sont des
figures de cette opposition mais non il
y a pas de partie au sens français du
terme Bernard Hourcade vous parlez de
révolution culturelle et pas politique
il y a un événement très important il y
a eu une révolution en culturelle en
Iran fondamentale profonde concernant
qui est parti des femmes c'est à fait
original et on sait pourquoi ça a été
bien analysé dans cette révolution
culturelle qui concerne le place des
femmes et ensuite la place des jeunes et
d'une façon générale la contestation de
la culture islamique imposée ces
généralisé c'est une vraie révolution
culturelle parce que désormais elle est
un peu irréversible tout le monde est
d'accord avec cela les sondages le
montraient mais sondages du gouvernement
montré que les 80% ou 90% la population
iranienne soutenaient un mouvement
libéral pour sortir un peu du ghetto
dans lequel ils étaient non il y a un
mouvement qui est irréversible dit un
moment dans cette même chaîne que
c'était un mouvement une une un conflit
de basse intensité de forte intensité
forte int réalité c'est à dire c'est
enraciner ce n'est pas direction
culturelle pour la littérature
uniquement c'est une révolution de
l'existence déjà des gens veulent une
façon de vivre une façon d'être
différente mais est-ce que ça peut
suffire à faire tomber le régime c'est
la question principale il peut trier
voir une révolution culturelle et le
régime peut être assez habile et le
régime islamique ma foi a montré son
efficacité par la répression par des
modalités différentes pour pouvoir
continuer à survivre vous avez 43 ans
que ça fonctionne tout en faisant des
concessions et la question principale
qu'il y a et s'attendent être clairement
intermittent c'est-à-dire en gare de
régime révolutionnaire effectué à cette
nombre d'appareils on garde l'argent on
garde le pouvoir on garde les réseaux et
on fait des concessions sur les femmes
qui pourront porter de shader plus ou
moins qui rend mal de foot donc cette
révolution culturelle elle peut être
contenue par le régime qui va trouver
des moyens de résister de plus que
l'opposition politique structurée n'est
pas encore structurée et donc ce
mouvement va continuer effectivement
comme ça a été dit ce mouvement continue
mais il faut bien aussi ne pas aller
trop loin les manifestations de vendredi
à zahedence lors de la prière et tout le
monde y va pour des raisons très
particulières et renforcé par la
situation actuelle ces différents
la taille des villes aussi exactement
les mouvements j'ai fait une carte
regardant les gens qui avaient manifesté
d'après les renseignements que l'on a
d'environ et qui n'ont pas manifesté les
villes où on a manifesté ont en moyenne
400 000 habitants les vives n'a pas
manifesté ont en moyenne 80000 habitants
c'est-à-dire grosso modo que dans les
grandes villes pour des raisons qui
incompréhensibles de panique de
répression les gens ont pu manifester et
ont manifester ils sont d'une ça c'est
fait dans les petites villes et moins
passé parce que contrôle social les plus
importants mais aussi un élément
important en 2019 c'est pas vieux il y a
eu des manifestations dans les petites
villes pour le prix de l'essence genre
gilets jaunes si vous voulez et dans les
grandes villes on n'a pas manifesté
il y a eu à l'époque près d'un millier
de morts en trois jours et ces petites
villes sont d'accord pour l'évolution
culturelle mais concrètement la pression
économique la pression sociale la
pression répression Texas il y a là une
question qu'il faut voir et de ne pas
trop être émotionnel par la répression
dramatique qui existe qu'il faut
regarder pourquoi aujourd'hui cette
révolution culturelle n'est pas encore
alors traduite en terme politique on y
reviendra évidemment ça va être l'un des
axes de notre débat mais je voudrais
qu'on parle de cette répression selon
les chiffres de l'ONJ norvégienne et
human right au moins 481 personnes ont
été tuées depuis début des
manifestations sirines c'est le travail
du collectif d'avocats auxquels vous
appartenez que vous représentez sur ce
plateau collecté d'épreuves pour juger
un jour les auteurs et les donneurs
d'ordre derrière ces chiffres et je
voudrais vous entendre là-dessus il y a
des schémas de violence dedans c'est
quoi cette schéma de violence alors ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que le
travail de notre collectif aujourd'hui
c'est de collecter des preuves il y a
des schémas effectivement qui se dessine
alors concrètement on va être concret
c'est les tableaux de la mort c'est les
tableaux de l'horreur c'est-à-dire que
toute la journée nos équipes vont faire
un inventaire des exactions vont les
qualifier juridiquement et se dessine du
coup un certain nombre de choses la
première c'est qu'il y a des
infanticides c'est-à-dire que il y a 70
personnes qui sont des enfants donc
moins de 18 ans voire même dans une
moindre proportion des enfants de moins
de 10 ans qui sont des victimes par
incident c'est à dire que ils
manifestaient ou alors il se trouvaient
à proximité d'une manifestation ils vont
prendre une balle perdue voilà ça c'est
70 jeunes gens qui font l'objet des
infanticides on a les violences
sexuelles imposées notamment aux femmes
mais pas que aux femmes aux prisonniers
aux détenus donc un certain nombre de
schémas ça va être l'apartheit je dirais
de genre jusqu'à
jusqu'au prison donc ça se ça se
manifeste comme ça
de personnes à titre de torture ou pour
obtenir des aveux forcés c'est souvent
schéma là ensuite on a le schéma des
condamnations à mort alors ça ça fait
également partie de l'arsenal répressif
c'est connu c'est dans l'ADN de la
République islamique c'est pas nouveau
le fait d'utiliser des condamnations à
mort pour désinciter les manifestants ça
c'est quelque chose qui a été fait dès
le début en fait avec la République
islamique puisque dès leur arrivée au
pouvoir ils ont étendu déjà les chefs
d'accusation possible de l'appel de mort
pendant que vous nous parlez on voit des
visages de de jeunes femmes de femmes
alors de qui s'agit son quinze jeunes
femmes en réalité qui sont actuellement
détenus à la prison de catchoc donc qui
est se trouve à caradj à une trentaine
de kilomètres de Téhéran ces jeunes
femmes leur seul crime en fait c'est
c'est d'être allé manifester en fait
contre contre le régime et aujourd'hui
elle se trouve en détention provisoire
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que ces
jeunes femmes elles avaient entamé une
grève de la faim qui a été brisée
d'ailleurs
dans des circonstances de qu'on peut
dont on peut supposer par les chevaliers
elles n'ont pas accès à leurs avocats
elles n'ont pour certaines pas connu les
charges dont elles sont accusées et la
communication pour certaines d'entre
elles avec leurs familles et quasiment
impossible voilà et d'ailleurs je
précise que ce matin l'une d'entre elles
très courageusement à adresser un
courrier d'ailleurs qui a été relayé par
les médias un certain nombre de médias
en expliquant que les conditions de la
détention pour ces femmes et évidemment
épouvantable donc il y a les
infanticides il y a les violences
sexuelles qui visent surtout les femmes
mais pas seulement les condamnations à
mort et puis alors il y a aussi les
sportifs qui sont visés on va voir des
portraits de sportifs pourquoi les
sportifs sont-ils visés par le régime
alors moi je je suis avocate donc
pourquoi j'ai juste un début peut-être
de réponse parce que les sportifs en
fait ils ont déjà un rapport à leur
corps qui est libre c'est leur
instrument c'est-à-dire que les
grimpeurs les alpinistes voilà ils sont
évidemment dans un rapport qui n'est pas
celui de la République islamique ce sont
des alpinistes exactement et d'ailleurs
cette photo a été relayée par des des
comités de montagn français qui ont été
saisis et donc c'est dans cet esprit
d'ailleurs de solidarité qui dépasse les
frontières entre montagnards on se sert
les coudes et qui ont relayé
effectivement un appel de la communauté
des athlètes et des alpinistes iraniens
alors ils sont détenus alors pour
certains notamment des na elle a été
libérée sous caution pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont ils sont visés ces sportifs
déjà c'était la la grimpeuse vous vous
souvenez peut-être en octobre 2022 qui
avait justement
tout à fait elle était allée à une
compétition internationale en enlevant
son hijab et évidemment elle avait reçu
un petit comité d'accueil un peu corsé à
son retour au pays pourquoi est-ce qu'on
les cite parce que ça participe au soft
power en fait c'est tous ces athlètes
ces sportifs qui vont faire des
compétitions à l'international c'est
aussi un visage de l'Iran et donc le
fait de les inclure dans l'arsenal de
répression c'est aussi de vouloir
maîtriser l'image que on donne de l'Iran
qui n'est pas une image islamique en
l'occurrence on les voit ces jeunes gens
ils sont tout à fait tourner vers
l'Occident d'ailleurs
Daina elle est aussi professeur de yoga
et snowboard donc voilà c'est une image
qui colle pas avec ce que veut nous
faire croire la République islamique
d'Iran voilà en tout cas c'est une
interprétation encore une fois c'est
vraiment intéressant de de vous allez
faire justement ce travail de
recensement effectivement des des
violences et des et de la répression
farivalid sur sur la réponse je voudrais
qu'on rentre un peu dans le détail de la
réponse du pouvoir parce que judicieux
on a un peu l'impression que c'est
monolithique il y a que la violence et
la répression est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué que ça est-ce qu'il y a des
espaces je je pose une question de B
aussi peut-être que je suis à côté de la
plaque mais j'assume est-ce qu'il y a
aussi des espaces finalement de
discussions de négociation de
d'intercession entre le pouvoir et ceux
qui mènent la révolte c'est une
excellente question et je pense que
en fait ce qui est extraordinaire entre
autres avec le mouvement famili liberté
suite à l'assassinatoires mini c'est
qu'on a enfin la réponse à cette
question parce que c'est une question
que beaucoup d'Iraniens se pose de bien
certain temps je dis ça dans le sens où
est-ce que le régime est formable dans
l'intérieur c'est pas tellement une
question de réforme je pense que le
million de dire un lien qui avait voté
pour des présidents entre guillemets
réformateurs ça va être très bien que le
système n'était pas réformable mais ils
espèrent on va dire peut-être un
effondrement à la soviétique ou un
scénario un peu en tout cas moins
sanglante je pense que aujourd'hui
encore une fois son généralisées une
grande partie de la population iranienne
pense que le système ne peut pas de
l'Intérieur donner une réponse et
j'avais envie de revenir sur la
discussion qu'on a eu on parlait de
révolution culturelle est-ce que la
révolution culturelle peut mener à une
révolution politique moi je suis
persuadé que oui parce que une dictature
religieuse s'oppose sur des éléments
entre guillemets culturels ou culturels
religieux vous avez des lignes rouges
dans une dictature religieuse vous avez
des lignes rouges religieuses
aujourd'hui un espace avec ce mouvement
là c'est que les Iraniens
disent qu'on veut pas de ces lignes
rouges donc c'est très intéressant parce
que quand on analyse à la fin en fait
c'est une question de laïcité de la
neutralité de l'État de la séparation de
la politique et de la religion donc on
ne pouvait pas avoir une réponse à
l'intérieur du système parce que le
système est une ça s'appelle une
république islamique ça n'a rien de
républicain mais c'est un régime
religieux comment vous pouvez séparer le
politique et à la religion dans un
système religieux d'ailleurs elle est
entre guillemets grande figure qui
ciseaux informateur en Iran aujourd'hui
ne prennent pas position sur ce
mouvement donc ça montre aujourd'hui que
l'alternative se trouve en dehors de ce
panel qui a existait déjà Bernard oucade
oui je suis d'accord avec prolongé ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure je suis
d'accord avec le fait que les gens en
Iran veut le changement mais la question
est très pratiquement comment y arriver
et ce n'est pas par miracle par un a
fait le Saint-Esprit ou du 12e immeuble
qui va arriver qui a fait une révolution
faire partir les molles et donc il faut
faire attention de mon point de vue je
ne suis pas iranien le changement de
gouvernement en Iran c'est pas mon
problème c'est la question des Iraniens
d'Iran en particulier par contre en tant
que citoyen la liberté la démocratie de
toute population m'intéresse je
m'intéresse surtout au fait qu'il y a
dans ces populations et ça fait 40 ans
ou 50 ans que 30 ans 40 ans que l'on
analyse là en sciences sociales ces
gens-là se révoltent de façon un peu
originale ce qui est important c'est
comment cette dynamique peut évoluer et
dans quelle mesure cette année unique à
secoué le régime et ce qui a des
fissures des factures qui ont été
provoquées parce que le régime beau être
dictatorial despotique et enfermé de
plus en plus dans cette logique là et on
pourra en discuter tout à l'heure et
peut-être certains les poussent à cette
radicalité
on pensait que ça va faire exploser le
système il y a des fractures à
l'intérieur mais il faut les analyser
jusqu'à maintenant malheureusement on
insiste beaucoup sur les morts sur la
répression tout ceci est vrai c'est pas
nouveau on découvre cela je les ai tout
à l'heure en 2019 il y a 1000 morts on a
pas parlé une petite note dans les
journaux c'était tout on a très parler
et tant mieux si aujourd'hui tant mieux
si aujourd'hui on met des choses devant
mais on a aujourd'hui un mouvement
extrêmement puissant et fort qui de mon
point de vue peut aboutir à un
changement profond en Iran du
gouvernement est plus qu'un gouvernement
parce que très bien changé la République
d'islamique avoir une dictature encore
au pire de main c'est possible on n'en
sais rien en soyons prudent et essayons
de voir les fissures et je pense qu'il y
a effectivement dans le système iranien
on l'a vu chez les religieux par exemple
chez des religions se souvient que quand
monsieur raï ici le président actuel a
contribué à massacrer déjà en prison en
était pas un tendre et ni un libéral
mais un bon musulman c'est opposé à cela
en disant on peut pas tuer les gens
comme cela et remédie la vider l'ami de
côté il était ostracisé il y a chez les
religieux aujourd'hui en Iran chez les
ayatollah et Akon des gens que l'on
connaît bien qui ont fait du bouquin qui
publie à l'étranger quelquefois disant
République et islam ça n'a pas marché on
a essayé ça n'a pas marché qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire ils sont en train de
penser à une réforme de la charia et la
charia c'est le loi le Code civil si
vous voulez le Code civil tel qu'il est
appliqué dans beaucoup de pays musulmans
étant que civil fait il y a 500 ans donc
il y a des fissures regardons cela je
n'ai pas je vous interrompre est-ce
qu'il y a je l'ai encore je pose mes
mots à moi mais est-ce qu'il y a un
courant réformiste qui existe au sein de
de voilà de de ce régime démola qui
pourrait prendre le pouvoir à l'occasion
de cette clé tout peut se faire le
problème est que grâce à Monsieur Trump
le qui a arrêté l'accord sur le
nucléaire qui permettait une certaine
évolution
parce que ça aurait pu devenir mais
c'est une possibilité d'économiques
auraient pu être culturelle et politique
aujourd'hui les les réformateurs étaient
éliminés ceux qui ont été pour l'accord
sur une élections ont été éliminés
aujourd'hui les radicaux sont au pouvoir
et dans tout ce qui renforce les
radicaux bloque le système bien
évidemment alors ça provoque vous voulez
l'un et l'autre réagir peut-être vous
commencez Farid
juste un petit point on parle des
réformistes ce qu'on appelle la réforme
East comme s'ils n'ont jamais le pouvoir
en Iran ils ont été au pouvoir pendant
16 ans en fait force cette constater
qu'ils n'arrivent pas soit ils veulent
pas faut pas non plus croire qu'on
dirait formiste on parle pas d'un
républicain la carte française on parle
dans le dans la structure de la
République islamique ils peuvent pas
changer les choses parce que les
institutions liées au guide vraiment
avec les deux l moi j'appelle les deux
ailes des gardiens de révolution et du
clergé ne laisse aucune réforme prendre
forme en oignon vous êtes face à un
système qui est extrêmement corrompu on
en parle pas beaucoup je trouve on dit
tout le temps sur l'Iran la République
démoulins moi je trouve qu'il faut dire
la République des mollets et des
gardiens vous avez toute une oligarchie
qui part religieuse c'est des civils
mais qui ont des intérêts économiques
majeurs liés au régime mais eux ils
lâcheront pas le régime parce que leur
intérêt économique sont extrêmement
majeurs et donc moi je ne vois pas
comment dans le cadre de ce système en
fait ce système est tellement désolé le
produit vulgaire mais pourri de
l'intérieur qu'aujourd'hui les dernières
se disent ok bon en fait faut le mal
vous faites c'est tellement racinaire il
faut tout couper et construire quelque
chose de nouveau un mot là-dessus
ensuite on ouvre un chapitre sur le
l'Iran et la France qui va être
passionnant lui aussi
rapidement moi je suis un peu en
désaccord avec vous cher Monsieur mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit qu'une
révolution culturelle moi les mots
d'ordre que j'entends moi les mots
d'ordre que j'entends de la part des
jeunes Iraniens et plus largement qui
les slogans c'est fin du régime mort à
layatollahomeini fin de cette théocratie
donc en fait c'est une aspiration à la
fois un régime démocratique et à la fin
de l'émission du religieux dans le
politique donc c'est pas qu'une
révolution culturelle là ce sont des
mots d'ordre qui sont véritablement
politique aujourd'hui alors sur le fait
de savoir si ces modes sont incarnés
politiquement par une opposition ça je
crois que c'est un autre débat mais sur
le fait de savoir s'il y a vraiment une
inspiration une inspiration à la
démocratie ça je crois que le message
est très clair venant de l'Iran et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec le fait
que ce régime aujourd'hui n'est pas
réformable et d'ailleurs le fait que
précisément les bien
les personnes qui incarnaient d'ailleurs
le courant réformiste aujourd'hui ne
s'exprime pas mais parce qu'ils savent
que finalement leur parole elle est pas
attendue elle est pas attendue de la
part des Iraniens donc il y a aussi ça
qu'il faut je pense avoir en tête oui un
tout petit mot rapide j'ai dit il y a
une victoire culturelle la révolution
culturelle a réussi c'est fait c'est une
première étape importante avec un
objectif politique évidemment donc ne
sous-estimons pas la puissance de la de
l'existence et les revendications
fondamentales des gens qui doivent
traduire en termes politiques et c'est
là qu'il faut être un peu plus habile et
quelquefois parce que on a un régime
despotique très fort qui se replie sur
lui-même de plus en plus qui adore Ré et
quand le condam de tous côtés pour être
une Corée du Nord qui réprime encore
plus en étant totalement alternative je
n'en sais rien j'ai pas nos politiques
j'essaie de voir les rapports de force
récemment par exemple une délégation de
l'ONU est allée à Kaboul et à Kandar
pourtant il est allé banc
qu'est-ce que ça m'a donné ils ne vont
pas changer d'avis après une délégation
de l'ONU quand il y a un combat dur il
faut pas fuir le combat il faut
affronter et pour affronter ce n'est pas
encore en isolant le pays en isolant les
gens qu'on veut combattre qu'on va les
combattre il faut compter les affronter
ce de toute façon toutes les façons
possibles ce n'est pas en coupant les
relations diplomatiques on va arriver
mais en multipliant contraire les
relations et la pression politique sur
l'Iran et là il y a mille façons de le
faire alors ça ouvre évidemment ça tombe
bien le chapitre que je voulais vous
proposer sur les relations entre l'Iran
et et la France et la question elle
rejoint d'ailleurs alors on avait lancé
notre sujet en même temps donc c'est
très bien la une de nos confrères du
magazine Le Point ce weekend pourquoi
l'Iran cible la France Mathieu on va
commencer par parler de d'Emmanuel
Macron
quelle attitude depuis le début du
mouvement c'est un peu la question qu'on
s'est posée en plusieurs temps ça
commence le 20 septembre on est quatre
jours après la mort de la jeune kurde et
se tient l'Assemblée générale des
Nations unies à New York et Emmanuel
Macron va rencontrer dans une rencontre
bilatérale Racing ils vont se serrer à
la main ça va donner lieu à des photos
et ça va lui être beaucoup reproché
parce que ça fait les gros titres de la
presse iranienne qui applaudit de demain
en disant que la France a toujours eu
une position particulière distincte des
États-Unis donc en Iran ça sert de
propagande mais chez les opposants chez
ceux qui commencent à se révolter c'est
une injure c'est une injustice ensuite
rendez-vous le 12 octobre sur France 2
là Emmanuel Macron dit qu'il condamne ah
oui alors pardon juste après l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies communiquer
voilà un tout petit communiqué où il est
question du nucléaire il est question de
Liban et de l'Irak et juste à la fin le
président de la République a dit le choc
qui a été le sien à la nouvelle de la
mort de Marsa mini après son arrestation
a insisté son ancestité qu'une enquête
transparente face la lumière sur ce
drapeau on est quasiment dans un fait
divers le 12 octobre changement
d'ambiance il y a eu toutes les
manifestations il y a eu le début de et
là évidemment le chef de l'État dit son
admiration pour les femmes pour les
jeunes qui manifestent de manière très
claire la France condamne la répression
menée aujourd'hui par le régime iranien
ça c'est ce qu'il dit et il va pousser
le bouchon alors là à ce moment-là le
régime démola réagit parle de d'un
gérance scandaleuse alors qu'ils ont
censé Macron un mois plus tôt Macron
devient un défenseur des droits de
l'homme prétentieux voilà ce qu'on
retrouve dans dans la presse iranienne
et dans la bouche des ministres
interrogés et puis un mois plus tard on
est le 11 novembre cette fois-ci
Emmanuel Macron reçoit des jeunes
iraniennes à l'Élysée et qualifie ce qui
se passe en Iran de révolution là encore
il devra se justifier de sa fameuse
poignée de main avec racis il le fera au
nom de la Real politique c'est-à-dire en
disant ben oui je continue à discuter
avec Poutine oui je dis continue à
discuter avec RACI parce que sur la
scène diplomatique on ne choisit pas
avec qui on discute mais on voit bien
que ça a été un difficile et en même
temps en tout cas incompréhensible pour
la population iranienne qui se soulevait
là-bas je rebondis sur le mot révolution
parce que il est tout sauf neutre dans
l'histoire et dans l'imaginaire iranien
quand un président français emploie ce
terme-là pour qualifier ces quatre mois
de de révolte qu'est-ce que comment
réagissent comment réagit le régime
qu'est-ce que ça signifie
une réaction pour les qualifier
hystérique finalement ils sont pas
forcément ils sont pas contents du tout
ils ont été encore plus sensibles aux
caricatures de Charlie Hebdo
du Président je pense que qualifier le
mouvement de révolutionnaire oui ça les
a crisper si les actrices sont encore
plus c'était de recevoir des militants
iraniennes à l'Élysée mais vous l'avez
très bonne expliqué de toute façon après
la poignée de main avec un ici et je
pense que le gouvernement français aussi
était quand même dans l'obligation
peut-être de d'avoir un acte fort un
geste fort à l'égard des Iraniens après
aujourd'hui les Iraniens faut pas non
plus croire ils sont ils sont quand même
très sensibles à la communication la
communication est une importance les
gestes symboliques ont une importance
après les Iraniens sont aussi un peuple
très politique et qui font la différence
des choses et je dis ça pour parler un
peu des sanctions de l'Union européenne
faut pas donner le sentiment ça serait
très dangereux de le sentiment d'y a un
lien que finalement on prend quelques
décisions symboliques qui ont certes une
importance politique
mais sans réelle conséquence concrètes
sur le terrain moi je suis partiellement
très dubitatif sur les sanctions
européennes parce que les Américains ont
déjà sanctionné l'Iran mais massivement
et par le biais de l'extra territorité
du droit américain l'Europe aujourd'hui
n'a pas de relation économique avec les
rangs donc on doit être lucide avec
nous-même et sincères si on veut et je
l'ai déjà dit si on veut vraiment faire
mal à la République islamique pour aller
faire mal à la relation entre la
réplique samedi et la Chine cette
alliance qui se forme entre Lyon et la
Russie c'est quand même un jeu
géopolitique très complexe qui se passe
entre quelques régimes sans tomber dans
des caricatures je sais qu'on a des
alliés pas très démocratiques mais
globalement vous avez quand même
quelques pays autoritaires qui forment
une alliance stratégique contre les
puissances libérales occidentales et bon
on en parlera aussi de du Parlement
européen de la commission je pense
qu'aujourd'hui aussi c'est un peu on
donne une très mauvaise image aux
Iraniens avec ses contradictions entre
le Parlement et la Commission mais faut
prendre toutes ces décisions vraiment et
cette prise de position au sérieuse
parce que après ça a des conséquences
très concrètes sur le thé alors vous
évoqué Charlie Hebdo effectivement ce
concours international de caricatures
organisée par nos confrères de de
Charlie Charlie Hebdo des caricatures de
laiatelas ramené l'actuel guide suprême
de la révolution iranienne numéro
spécial de Charlie qui a provoqué ces
menaces du chef des Gardiens de la
Révolution
je conseille aux Français et au
responsables du magazine Charlie Hebdo
de se pencher sur le sort de Salman
Rushdie
[Musique]
plaisante pas avec les musulmans
pendant pas pour changer de régime
uniquement à trouver un pire mais
vraiment changer profondément ce t
iranienne la question que je me pose
est-ce que les caricatures Charlie Hebdo
ont aidé le peuple iranien dans son
combat avec le gouvernement iranien qui
s'est radicalisé pour dire regarder
c'est fille qui veulent pas le shador ce
sont des prostituées c'est n'importe
quoi et la pression est encore plus
forte ça donne une cohésion au régime ce
n'est pas qu'il faille innocenter le
régime mais soyons un peu intelligent et
quand on a des gens en danger des otages
n'y reviendra je pense dans un instant
ou une population qui est en train de se
révolter essayons de ne pas titiller les
les acteurs c'est la liberté de Charlie
Hebdo et des caricaturistes du monde
entier moi je suis pas d'accord avec
vous là dessus mais bon voyons les
effets sur les gens concrètement soyons
on peut très bien être libre en France
puis après on leur dira on leur dira si
s'il y a s'ils sont visés par un
attentat que ils avaient une part de
responsabilité ils ont bien cherché mais
c'est un peu si on entend quand vous
dites ça soyons soyons intelligents on a
des choses à faire il faut le faire il
faut prévoir les sanctions qu'il faudra
faire regardons la dynamique et évitons
évitons sans abdiquer de nos idées
évitant de faire des choses qui soient
contraires à l'intérêt du peuple iranien
votre réponse à ça oui alors je suis de
nouveau en désaccord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit pourquoi parce que je reviens
j'ai pas eu l'occasion de revenir sur le
en même temps diplomatique mais c'est
quand même un peu lié je crois que là
l'heure n'est plus offert du en même
temps c'est à dire qu'à un moment il
faut choisir son camp et moi je le dis
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a clairement le
camp des bourreaux c'est à dire les
Gardiens de la Révolution et les mots là
qui font de la diplomatie de la corde et
de la mort c'est à dire que ils
exécutent des prisonniers politiques les
Gardiens de la Révolution je suis navré
mais ils sont quand même à l'origine
d'une prise d'otage il y a plus d'une
dizaine d'otages aujourd'hui qui sont
des otages européens on le sait ce sont
les gardiens de la révolution qui les
détiennent on a eu cette expression vous
l'avez vu du chef en fait des Gardiens
de la révolution qui menacent en fait la
preuve sur les otages mais si vous
disiez ça sert pas finalement le ces
caricatures de Charlie Hebdo ça sert pas
la Révolution la révolte qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous et si dans un pays
où en fait la liberté d'expression
n'existe pas que la liberté de
caricaturer n'existe pas que la liberté
de blasphème n'existe pas si pardon mais
mais le fait d'avoir une presse libre en
France qui en solidarité en fait publie
ses caricatures là c'est accueilli par
la population très favorablement
d'ailleurs on a vu que nombre de
manifestants utilisaient les visuels de
Charlie Hebdo dans leur manifestation
donc c'est évidemment de nécessaire
le le gage de la subtilité de son propos
c'est-à-dire il nous dit même si j'étais
un peu critique et pas d'accord avec
vous sur le fait que Charlie et le droit
et même peut-être ça super qu'il les
fait moi mais bon voilà je sais pas
j'essaye de pas trop rentrer là-bas mais
vous nous dites attention ça ça
participe de la radicalisation et du
renfermement de de ce régime qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça le problème le
régime aujourd'hui il ne représente que
lui-même il faut bien comprendre qu'il y
a deux camps il y a le camp en fait de
la base la société civile les jeunes qui
s'organisent et il y a ce régime donc à
la limite que ce régime se radicalise
très bien mais en réalité Charlie Hebdo
est plus largement la communauté
internationale il faut qu'elle envoie
aussi des gages à la population en
disant on vous soutient en solidarité
donc la question c'est à qui on part à
qui on parle et quand Charlie Hebdo fait
ses caricatures ce qu'elle dit aux
jeunes qui se mobilisent c'est on est en
soutien la France vous regarde la France
des Lumières la France de la caricature
vous vous soutien manifester c'est le
problème une minorité très active et
importante fondamentale et courageuse à
manifester la majorité des Iraniens
hélas mille fois hélas ne sait pas jouer
au mouvement donc regardons cela
essayons de voir comment une révolution
une révolution c'est c'est pas parce que
la majorité des Iraniens ne vont pas
dans la rue parce qu'on sait
qu'effectivement il y a des risques pour
leur vie que ils ne sont pas largement
favorables pour un pignon n'est
largement vu durable au renversement du
régime tout à fait
ce qu'on entend par ailleurs parfois en
France en disant bah il y a une majorité
silencieuse qui ne s'exprime pas voilà
là aujourd'hui en Iran la majorité des
équations c'est pour faire tomber le
régime on y revient voilà pour faire
tomber le régime jusqu'à combien combien
faut-il de de personnes dans le dans les
rues mais ça ne peut pas se définir
comme ça dans un dans un régime dans
lequel le droit de manifester n'existe
pas et ou quand vous allez dans la rue
vous vous prenez des balles
pardonnez-moi mais ça ne peut pas être
l'Alpha et l'Oméga le savoir de le fait
de savoir combien de personnes sont dans
la rue le comptage des manifestants dans
ce contexte particulier ne peut pas nous
nous aider à trouver les leviers qui
pourraient faire tomber le le
régime maintenant et toujours en place
et de plus en plus radicale il commence
à exécuter des gens de façon sordide
donc essayons de voir pour comment cette
révolution qui est en marche changement
profond peut continuer d'avancer et
faisons tout nous autres en France dans
nos pour ne pas aller dans un sens qui
bloquerait encore plus alors le sens du
régime actuellement beaucoup de choses
que l'on fait ici vont dans le sens de
la diatole Roumanie ramenéi et je ne
suis pas d'accord tout à l'heure vos
arguments aux uns et aux autres on va
parler des otages pour terminer je
propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre tout de suite sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Steve alors on parle 7
ressortissants français sont détenus en
Iran qui sont-ils oui au moins cette au
moins 7 sont actuellement détenus j'ai
dit au moins car ça pourrait être plus
en 7 c'est le chiffre officiellement
communiquer par le Quai d'Orsay on va
voir la liste on va commencer avec
Benjamin Brière il a 37 ans c'est un
touriste qui a été arrêté il y a deux
ans et demi pour espionner j'ai
propagande contre le régime et la
photographie des zones interdites avec
son drone il a été condamné à 8 ans de
prison fariba adelrade c'est une
chercheuse franco-y iranienne elle a été
arrêtée en juin 2019 puis condamné à 50
prisons pour atteinte à la sécurité
nationale il s'agit d'une
une liste de l'islam chiite et de l'Iran
à Sciences Po Cécile Kohler est
enseignante elle a été arrêtée avec son
compagnon Jacques Paris en mai 2022
alors qu'il faisait du tourisme dans le
pays le régime les accusent d'être des
espions Bernard filant 64 ans à lui
était arrêté le 3 octobre 2022 il était
en déplacement professionnel il est
consultants pour un tout opérateur deux
autres ressortissants français sont
également détenus leur identité mais en
revanche pas connu alors du côté du
gouvernement français on dit tout faire
pour obtenir la libération de ces 7
prisonniers en décembre Catherine
Colonna assuré avoir échangé avec son
homologue iranien écoutez-la je lui ai
parlé brièvement dans dans la salle du
sommet pour lui demander à nouveau la
libération immédiate des otages qui sont
détenus par l'Iran et le plein respect
du droit international humanitaire
et pas seulement du droit international
humanitaire du droit international en
général c'est à dire respecter ses
obligations internationales tant pour ce
qui a très au droit civils et politiques
comme le dit le Pacte des naissances
Unies que de la noningérance dans les
affaires d'autrui comme le recommande la
Charte des Nations Unies certains de ces
prisonniers sont dans un état de santé
préoccupant on rappelle qu'ils n'ont pas
d'avocat indépendants et ne peuvent pas
donner de nouvelles à leurs proches sauf
très rares exceptions Thomas c'est
détention évidemment utiliser pour faire
pression contre la France ou d'autres
pays occidentaux ce sont des otages
d'État c'est le terme qui est utilisé
par le gouvernement français autrement
dit on parle de détention arbitaire
utilisée comme une stratégie
diplomatique par le régime iranien la
méthode n'est pas nouvelle elle est
appliquée depuis la révolution islamique
de 1979 on appelle ça la diplomatie de
l'otage l'idée c'est de monnayer de la
libération de prisonniers pour obtenir
gain de cause sur d'autres dossiers par
exemple sur le nucléaire iranien on va
voir quelques chiffres Thomas en 2020
l'ONG Human Right Watch recensé 14 cas
de binationaux ou d'étrangers arrêtés en
Iran depuis 2014 en octobre 2022 une ONG
américaine comptabilisée elle au moins
20 personnes détenues aujourd'hui il y a
plus d'ambassade américaine en Iran ce
sont donc les Européens qui sont visés
en priorité dans le cadre de cette
diplomatie demain merci beaucoup Quentin
pour toutes ces
inforoustilles Jourdain et pas Quentin
calmé excusez-moi Farida pourquoi le
régime on l'a un peu expliqué prend des
otages et quel comment il utilise
ensuite qu'est-ce qui se passe après le
après l'arrestation et l'incarcération
d'un de français ou de binationaux déjà
faut quand même le dire c'est absolument
inacceptable c'est des techniques de
voyou je qualifierais ça vraiment des
techniques de voyou donc de détruire la
vie de personnes innocentes de les
mettre en prison pendant des années de
les séparer de leur famille mais
pourquoi ils le parce que ça ça rejoint
finalement le débat sur Charlie Hebdo et
le reste parce que on a montré que ça
marche malheureusement en fait ils le
font parce que ils l'ont fait avec dans
un exorable il ira au britannique
pendant des années le temps en prison ça
paraît de sa fille à la prison des
vignes et à la fin elle est britanniques
c'est des règles un dossier juridique
avec plaisir ils le font maintenant avec
les Français parce qu'ils se disent
qu'ils vont avoir des cartes à jouer
lors des négociations nucléaires parce
qu'en 2015 ils ont pu le faire donc moi
je suis désolé mais à un moment je pense
face à des états qui comprennent que la
puissance et le pouvoir nous certes on
est des démocraties mais faut montrer
qu'on est pas non plus faible et qu'on
n'est pas naïf qu'on peut être puissant
si quand Charlie Hebdo publie des
caricatures ma connaissance dans un pays
libre et à la liberté de la presse
allez-y on est aujourd'hui inspire à
avoir la même chose ils prennent à la
France mais nos valeurs comme modèle la
laïcité la liberté de la presse la
liberté de penser donc moi je trouve que
c'est extraordinaire en tant qu'iranien
je le soutiens en complément
complètement Charlie parce que qu'est-ce
qu'ils font les erreurs aujourd'hui ils
brisent des sabots qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
Charlie une prise de tabou finalement
c'est la même chose et les Iraniens les
reprennent et apprécient beaucoup mais
vous nous disiez tout à l'heure que les
les sanctions économiques finalement
n'avaient pas provoqué les effets
escomptés donc quand vous dites il faut
montrer un front plus plus de enfin
répondre à la force par la force déjà
les sanctions économiques c'est un
dossier technique on prend pas pendant
des heures ils ont quand même des effets
les faits c'est la disparition de la
classe moyenne iranienne et c'est des
conséquences économiques majeures on a
quand même des leviers de pression
diplomatique on peut par exemple
rappeler peut-être notre ambassadeur il
y a la question des des gardiens de
révolution sur la liste des
organisations terroristes il y a quand
même on a beaucoup de moyens on peut
aussi intensifier notre relation avec la
société civile avec les opposants je
pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup de
choses mais faut surtout pas le donner
le sentiment avec des des états comme la
République islamique ou comme la Russie
c'est vous donner le faut pas négocier
il faut laisser les otages moi je dis
juste que si vous infinie faut négocier
moi je dirais pas avec ce régime là en
tout cas en fait non
mais imaginez oui ça pourrait ils sont
en train d'exécuter des jeunes en Iran
imaginez Catherine Colonna allait
négocier avec mon ministre ses affaires
étrangères iraniens en ce moment quel
message on donnera aux Iraniens c'est
juste qu'on s'en fout de un moment faut
je pense qu'on fait aussi le site parler
de quoi de toute façon aujourd'hui ça
les Iraniens qui n'ont pas vous voulu
négociez avec nous ils ont déjà laissé
un lien n'ont pas la République
islamique n'ont pas attendu les
caricatures de Charlie Hebdo pour se
radicaliser
un mot de conclusion il nous reste
quelques secondes il est certain que
l'État voyou de la République islamique
est une réalité c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la question qui se pose
c'est pourquoi la masse la population
n'a pas rejoint le système et pourquoi
nos otages ont pris son prix est-ce
qu'il faut prendre des décisions
symboliques qui renforcent la paranoïa
du cirque qui l'isole en Corée du Nord
et donc ça bloquera encore plus la
dynamique de la population et ça
maintiendra nos otages ou bien est-ce
qu'il faut être imaginatif et
effectivement le cas iranien tout à fait
original et il faut avoir une
originalité en matière de politique
merci beaucoup on a entendu vos
arguments aux uns et aux autres on a
bien compris vous n'étiez pas forcément
d'accord sur la stratégie mais c'était
passionnant Bernard je vais rappeler le
titre de ce livre publié aux éditions du
CNRS s'y rend les paradoxes d'une nation
voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro de
comment s'appelle mon émission déjà sans
public vous êtes bien aimable et on est
à l'antenne à 18h et 22h sur Public
Sénat ne ratez pas c'était à ça que je
pensais dans la matinale demain deux
rendez-vous oralement signe reçoit
d'abord le ministre de la transformation
et de la fonction publique Stanislas
Guerini à 8h et puis 8h20 Olivier Faure
premier secrétaire d'un Parti socialiste
en pleine tourmente belle soirée
[Musique]